>> Mike: NEARLY TWO YEARS INTO
THE TRUMP PRESIDENCY, THE MAN
WHO MADE THE PHRASE "YOU'RE
FIRED" FAMOUS, HAS ALREADY SENT
FIVE CABINET MEMBERS PACKING.
THAT NUMBER COULD GROW AS
QUESTIONS AROUND THE FUTURES OF
RYAN ZINKE AND KIRSTJEN NIELSEN.
AND TONIGHT NIGHTS "WHATEVER
HAPPENED TO" SEGMENT, BRET BAIER
LOOKS AT RELATIONSHIPS WITH
OTHER CABINET MEMBERS WHO CAREER
CAME TO A SUDDEN END.
>> Bret: >> CHANGES TO CM
>> Bret: >> CHANGES TO C.
>> President Trump: I'M HAPPY
WITH ALMOST ALL OF MY CABINET.
IT'S CABINET.
>> Bret: BEFORE HE WAS
PRESIDENT, HE VOWED HE WOULD
BUILD HIS CABINET WITH TOP-NOTCH
NOMINEES.
>> President Trump: WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE ALL THE BEST
PEOPLE WE'RE GOING TO FIND OUT
WHO THEY ARE.
>> SOME DID NOT HAVE THE BEST
JUDGMENT.
>> Bret: SOME OF THE
PRESIDENT'S CABINET MEMBERS ARE
OPTING NOT TO FLY WITH THE
PUBLIC.
HEALTH AND HUMAN SECRETARY TOM
PRICE BECAME THE FIRST CASUALTY,
HE CAME INTO THE ADMINISTRATION
WITH HOPES OF HELPING CONGRESS
TO REPEAL AND REPLACE OBAMACARE.
>> FIXING THIS SITUATION
REQUIRES AN ACT OF CONGRESS.
>> Bret: THE SECRETARY HAD
USED PRIVATE JETS FOR OFFICIAL
BUSINESS, AT LEAST 26 TIMES AT A
COST OF MORE THAN 400,000
TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
AMID THE UPROAR, INCLUDING THAT
OF PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> President Trump: I'M NOT
HAPPY ABOUT IT AND I LET HIM
KNOW IT.
>> Bret: SECRETARY PRYCE TOLD
ME HE WOULD REPAY HIS DEBT.
YOU SAY IN THE STATEMENT THE
TAXPAYERS WON'T PAY A DIME BUT
YOUR WRITING A CHECK FOR
$51,887.
THE TOTAL COST IS ESTIMATED THAT
MORE THAN 400,000, 26 FLIGHTS
SINCE MAY.
IS THAT OKAY?
>> THERE IS AN ONGOING REVIEW
BEING DONE BY THE EXPECTED OR
GENERAL, IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
WAIT FOR THAT.
>> Bret: THE VERY NEXT DAY
AFTER LESS THAN TEN MONTHS ON
THE JOB, PRICE RESIGNED AT
SAYING HE DIDN'T WANT TO BE A
DISTRACTION TO THE WORK OF HHS.
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
ADMINISTRATOR SCOTT PRUITT HAD A
PROMISING START BUT HIS SPENDING
HABITS ALSO GOT IN WAY OF THE
AGENDA.
>> THERE HAVE BEEN VERY
TROUBLING MEDIA REPORTS.
>> Bret: HE FACED MONTHS OF
SCRUTINY OVER LAVISH SPENDING
AND ETHICS VIOLATIONS EVERYTHING
FROM PRICEY ROUND-THE-CLOCK
SECURITY TO SPENDING $43,000 ON
A SOUND PROOF PHONE BOOTH AND
EVEN REPORTS THAT HE ASKED
DONORS FOR HELP LANDING A JOB
FOR HIS WIFE.
ON THE FOURTH OF JULY HE WAS A
SPOTTED ATTENDING CELEBRATIONS
AT THE WHITE HOUSE, ONE DAY
LATER HE RESIGNED FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION.
[APPLAUSE]
>> President Trump: WILL NEVER
HAVE TO USE THOSE WORDS ON OUR
DAVID.
>> Bret: DAVID CHOKE AND WAS
THE ONLY HOLDOVER FROM THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION AND HIS
APPOINTMENT IN 2017 SEEM TO HOLD
GREAT PROMISE FOR THE TROUBLED
AGENCY, A PRACTICING DOCTOR HE
WOULD SOMETIMES MEET WITH
PATIENTS AT THE VA MEDICAL
CENTER AND VOWED TO TURN THE
AGENCY AROUND.
>> WE ARE FINALLY DEALING WITH
THE ISSUES THAT HAVE PLAGUED THE
SYSTEM FOR DECADES.
>> Bret: HIS ADMINISTRATION
CAME UNDER SCRUTINY FOLLOWING AN
INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT THAT
FOUND HE IMPROPERLY ACCEPTED
WIMBLEDON TICKETS AND AIRFARE
FOR HIS WIFE THAT COST TAXPAYERS
$122,000.
>> AND I DO REGRET THE DECISIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE THAT HAVE
TAKEN FOCUS OFF OF THAT
IMPORTANT WORK.
>> Bret: REGRETS WERE NOT
ENOUGH.
>> Bret: IT WAS USED IN A
POLITICAL WAY TO TRY TO REMOVE E
POLITICAL WAY TO TRY TO REMOVE .
IT'S WASHINGTON, I UNDERSTAND
THAT.
>> Bret: ADMINISTRATION
DOWNFALLS WERE NOT LIMITED TO
ETHICS PROBES.
OTHERS FELT THE PRESIDENTS WRATH
WHEN THEY OPPOSED HIM.
>> President Trump: HE WAS
RESPECTED ALL OVER THE WORLD.
>> Bret: REX TILLERSON WAS AN
UNLIKELY CANDIDATE FOR SECRETARY
OF STATE.
THE CEO OF A MASSIVE COMPANY
WITH LITTLE EXPERIENCE IN
POLITICS BUT ONE WHO HAD THE
COMPLETE SUPPORT OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP AT THE BEGINNIN
BEGINNING.
THE TWO SOON PUBLICLY CLASHED
OVER SEVERAL FOREIGN AFFAIRS
ITEMS, NOTABLY THE IRAN NUCLEAR
DEAL.
>> President Trump: REX AND I
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS FOR
THE LONG TIME WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE IRAN DEAL, I THINK IT'S
TERRIBLE, HE THINKS IT'S OKAY.
>> Bret: AND NORTH KOREA WITH
THE PRESIDENT WEEDING IN 2017
NETELLER'S AND WAS WASTING HIS
TIME TRYING TO NEGOTIATE WITH
"LITTLE ROCKET MAN."
PERHAPS THERE WAS WHAT BECAME
KNOWN AS THE "MOMENT" >> IN
PLACES I COME FROM, WE DON'T DEA
PLACES I COME FROM, WE DON'T DEL
PLACES I COME FROM, WE DON'T DEW
PLACES I COME FROM, WE DON'T DEH
PLACES I COME FROM, WE DON'T DET
PLACES I COME FROM, WE DON'T DEP
PLACES I COME FROM, WE DON'T DEY
NONSENSE.
>> Bret: RUMORS OF HIS DEMISE
BEGAN LAST NOVEMBER BUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP DIDN'T DUMP HIM
UNTIL MARCH.
>> MY COMMISSION AT SECRETARY OF
STATE WILL TERMINATE AT MIDNIGHT
MARCH 31ST.
>> Bret: HE WOULD LEAVE HIS
JOB JUST 435 DAYS AFTER BECOMING
SECRETARY OF STATE, ONE OF THE
SHORTEST TEN YEARS IN HISTORY.
>> WE NEED TO MAKE AMERICA GREAT
AGAIN.
>> Bret: THEN SENATOR JEFF
SESSIONS WAS ONE OF
DONALD TRUMP'S MOST ARDENT AND
EARLIEST SUPPORTERS ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
SOON AFTER HE WAS ELECTED,
PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE THE FORMER
ALABAMA SENATOR'S
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
>> President Trump: IT IS WITH
GREAT PRIDE, VERY GREAT PRIDE,
THAT I SAY THESE WORDS TO YOU
RIGHT NOW: ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF
SESSIONS.
>> Bret: HE SEEMS TO QUICKLY
FALL FROM FAVOR AFTER CHOOSING
TO RECUSE HIMSELF FROM THE
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION.
>> President Trump: I AM
DISAPPOINTED IN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
HE SHOULD NOT HAVE RECUSED
HIMSELF.
>> Bret: PRESIDENT TRUMP
PUBLICLY LAMBASTED HIM ON
SOCIAL MEDIA AGAIN AND AGAIN,
DESPITE THE DISCORD HE REMAINED
MOSTLY MOM ABOUT IT AS HE
REMAINED ON THE JOB.
>> Bret: HOW'S YOUR
RELATIONSHIP NOW?
THERE WAS ROCKY THERE FOR A
WHILE.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS CLEAR WHEN
HE'S HAPPY WITH SOMEBODY AND
WHEN HE'S NOT HAPPY WITH
SOMEBODY.
>> Bret: HE SAID HE WOULD'VE
LIKED A DO OVER.
>> President Trump: HE NEVER
TOOK CONTROL OF THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
>> Bret: PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS
HE WILL NOT FIRE HIS
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS
BEFORE THE NOVEMBER MIDTERM
ELECTIONS.
BUT AFTER THAT, THE PRESIDENT
WOULD NOT COMMIT.
>> Bret: IT FINALLY, ONE DAY
AFTER THE MIDTERMS THE PRESIDENT
OFFICIALLY ASKED SESSIONS FOR